Monday on Dancing with the Stars it is
switch-up night which is always a lot of
fun because that is where celebrities
swapped their Pro partners so front
runner at nyle DiMarco who is hearing
impaired has to do just that but
considering how far he has come all now
has more than proven there is no
challenge he can't conquer and I
actually heard that you actually prefer
to not feel the vibrations of the song
while you dance why is that I think for
me being born deaf I'm sound has never
existed in my life so I feel like when I
try to feel something or feel the music
and then dance it comes me off it cuz
it's it's contrary to what I know so I
can't work with it because I'm not used
to it
nyle is killing I mean who can forget
that Tarzan dance but he's switching
from Peta Murgatroyd to Sharna Burgess
who showed us how she gives physical
cues denial so he knows when to move
nyle is able to know when to start
sometimes not just because of taps and
obvious signals but because he can see
my body movement and catch on the rhythm
and the timing of it he won the 22nd
season of America's Next Top Model and
only et can show you what happened when
Tyra dropped by for a reunion so how the
hell do you make eye contact and hold it
because I would be like Tyra Banks
stopped by what was it like for you to
see her again oh I have to say you know
it was touching and honored that she
came to see my workers the our work you
know I was on her show and she trained
me and I think it's different for her to
come and see me work it means so much to
me to take the time to do that
now communicates through American Sign
Language the voice you hear is his
interpreter Raymond nor odd for me my
personal goal was to prove that you know
I can't actually work with anyone and
anyone can work with me I'll need the
world to realize that deaf people can do
whatever they can do